foreign
was to use the public markets to get
access to Capital create a new financial
model
um and and to make private Christian
higher education affordable to all
socioeconomic classes of Americans we
thought we had learned some things where
we were previously that could allow us
to do that
um we just didn't have any idea to be
honest with you that was going to turn
out this good
Grand Canyon University is a private
Christian University in Phoenix Arizona
uh it existed since back in 1949 uh it's
always a small private uh Christian
University uh non-denominational usually
had about thousand twelve hundred
students good programs in nursing and
education they did a great job all those
years but it was always uh you know on
the verge of closing from a financial
perspective uh we came here uh in in
um and there were less than a thousand
students on the campus there was debt we
were in a neighborhood it was very very
challenged from a crime perspective from
a poverty perspective
um but we thought we could use this to
create a new model for higher education
one that would make it affordable to all
social economic classes of Americans on
our campus today we have 25 500 students
every class is another record-breaking
class in terms of numbers last year it
was 9 700 new students on our campus
this year will be close to 11 000 new
students on our campus and uh has that
campus has grown to 25 500 students in
the next 10 years or or less it will
grow somewhere near 50 000 students
for competency we think is to understand
where the economy is going where the
jobs are going to be how people can
build great careers and how they can do
it without taking on large amounts of
debt nobody would would have thought
that a private university could be uh
more affordable affordable than a State
University which is heavily subsidized
but we are uh and uh we hope not to
raise tuition the next 10 years
it's a different model but it's one that
Embraces the use of technology and one
that uh Embraces understanding who the
student is what their life circumstances
are and being able to deliver according
to that student in those life
circumstances higher education should be
a great democratizing force in our
country but when tuitions go up every
time tuitions go up diversity goes down
uh and what we've been able to do is
create an environment where
socioeconomically we're extremely
diverse we get upper class kids up for
middle class kids but we also have this
huge scholarship program where we're
attracting very good uh students living
below the poverty line uh 3 000 of our 9
700 new students last year were
first-gen college students uh and when
you're able to do that you're able to
fulfill uh the real uh goal and
objective of higher education which is
to lift all boats